me to this workshop uh so i could talk
about this work with you
this is no seriously i'll be talking
about a joint paper with um who's at
george mason and an india at upenn
um so if you take one sentence away from
this talk the one sentence which kind of
encapsulates the whole thing is that
it's a talk about
a problem at the intersection of sparse
recovery and property testing
just the setup i think at least for me
takes a little bit of mental space to
kind of get it in my head properly so
i'll have a
gentle sort of ramp up to the to the
main substance of the talk by reminding
starting by reminding ourselves about
you know what is what are the basics of
sparse recovery
how does it mesh with the property
testing setting because even even i
think the statement of the result is a
little bit
um a little bit involved it takes could
maybe will require two looks for us so
okay i want to start with a little bit
of basic stuff about sparse recovery and
we'll uh go through this by
sort of considering a very um simple and
idealized example problem so that'll be
a problem of solving
a system of random linear equations so
what do we mean by this we have some
unknown solution vector
just a vector of n real numbers w1
through wn
and we're going to be interested in
solving random linear equations to which
to which this is the solution so
our first equation maybe is this thing
up top this linear combination
gives us seven the next linear
combination of the wi's gives us eleven
so on and so forth
so what do i mean by random here well
for now just to keep things very
concrete let's consider a really simple
clean model of what these random
equations are how they're formed which
is just that every coefficient is
independently plus one or minus one okay
so we see all these uh
you know positive w1 minus w2 minus w3
plus w4
they're all just formed by tossing coins
to come up with the coefficient
structure for the equations
so we can think about a system of random
linear equations like this as of course
a data set
a data set consisting of labeled
examples so we have these x
n bit strings x and we have the value w
dot x as the label
and our assumption that we have these
random linear equations where all the
coefficients are plus minus ones just
says that uh
the distribution over the x's if we want
to think about it from this perspective
is uniform over the boolean hyper cube
minus 1 1 to the n
okay so suppose we want to solve a
system of linear equations like this
this is of course something we all know
how to do if we get
n or maybe a little bit more than n
equations as long as we get n linearly
independent equations we can recover
the solution efficiently and this is of
course just gaussian elimination so
we're all very familiar with this this
is a simple problem
okay now i want to impose a little bit
of additional structure in the
assumptions let's think about solving a
system of random linear equations
where i actually know that the solution
is sparse okay
so it's not an arbitrary um solution
vector w and rn anymore that we're
thinking about instead
i promise you we know that the the
solution has only
k non-zero coefficient k non-zero
entries
okay so the solution we're looking for
is a very sparse vector think of k
is uh extremely small relative to the
ambient dimension
n so our system still looks something
like this
and it's well known kind of a
foundational result in this area of
compressive sensing is that if we have k
log
n equations now we don't need n
equations anymore because of this
sparsity assumption
it turns out that with only k log n
equations we can recover the vector
um efficiently and this is sort of a
cornerstone result in this whole area of
sparse recovery or compressed sensing
i'll talk a little bit more about this
coming up
um but before getting to kind of the
good stuff just sort of a
throwaway observation if we only care
about sample complexity this is actually
a very easy problem to solve
uh you can imagine well i know that the
solution vector w
is k sparse there's only n to the k
possible patterns and to the k locations
n choose k
places where those non-zero coefficients
could be so you could imagine just
trying each one of them in turn
if i have a given sparsity pattern i
only need k equations
in order to solve the system and so i
can just take my k equations
check if that is the right you know
solve see if i get a part see if i get a
solution which is then consistent with
my other equations
and that'll basically tell me if i had
the right sparsity pattern and got
things correct
okay so this is not a very time
efficient way to do it it's going to
take us something like n to the k
running time
but it's efficient in terms of sample
complexity so just a sort of quick
uh you know you can see with your own
eyes um
proof that the sample complexity of
solving this problem is is uh
very low it's going to be an easy
problem to solve
okay you don't have to be you know terry
tau or uh emmanuel candace or justin
romberg or david donahoe to come up with
that
the big contribution of this work that
these guys did was that of course you
can actually do this um in a
computationally efficient way you only
need polynomial time you don't need
n to the k time in order to do the
sparse recovery and this is by this
l1 l1 regression type algorithm it's
sort of
the condition that we imposed earlier
this sort of very toy problem where we
assume that the coefficient
the coefficients are uniform plus or
minus one values is
unnecessarily restrictive it's well
known that um
if you have a weaker property this
restricted isometry property that will
be enough
for the uh this algorithm to actually
succeed and efficiently be able to do
the sparse recovery from just k log n
equations
so again this is sort of just the tip of
the iceberg of a very large field
um but it sort of sets the stage for
what i want to be talking about in this
context
okay so that's our whirlwind tour of uh
sparse recovery kind of basics
let's move on now and get to the other
piece of the puzzle for us which is
property testing
so i think we all know what property
testing is we certainly will by the end
of the week or by the end of the day
today
the basic idea of property testing we
think about it is that there's some
massive object some really really big
thing maybe a distribution over an
enormous domain
or a boolean function with an
exponential size domain something like
that
and we want to figure out whether or not
the object has some property
while making just a small number of
local inspections we only want to look
at a very sublinear sort of portion of
the object
and figure out solve this decision
problem whether or not it has some
property
so just to remind us of kind of a
touchstone problem in property testing
that'll turn out to be
related at least in spirit to what we're
talking about is this well-known problem
of junta testing for boolean functions
so here we'll think of the sort of
unknown massive object as being an
n-variable boolean
function okay so that's you know you can
think of it as a pretty enormous object
of size 2 to the n
and the property we're interested in is
this property of whether or not the
function is a k
hunter so what does that mean it means
that the function really just depends on
k
out of the n input variables right it
looks like f of x one through x
n but in actuality it's really just some
function that depends on maybe
three of the input variables as in this
example
and our standard way of thinking about
property testing
for boolean functions is often that we
consider a setting where we get to
inspect the function via blackbox
queries so this is different than the
sort of sample based testing that eric
was talking about earlier
um you know the usual way we would think
about testing boolean functions is that
you have a membership oracle you have a
black box oracle you feed in an input
string
and you get back the value of the
function on that input
okay so as probably most of us know
there are some notable successes in this
area of boolean function property
testing this was one of the uh
early and very influential results by
fisher kindler ron
i think safra samaranitsky and there
were many refinements
by eric and other people over the years
saying that hey we actually have perhaps
surprisingly really efficient algorithms
for this property testing problem this
problem of testing whether an n variable
function
boolean function is actually a k junta
or not so we can solve this if
you give me any boolean function any n
variable function there's an efficient
algorithm which will say yes
if the function is a kehunta it will say
no if the function is far from every k
hunter epsilon far from every k junta
and you can do this with sort of this
gold standard sample complexity
you make a number of queries to the
whoops that should be queries to f
mcqueries to g
number of queries which is completely
independent of the ambient dimension
of sort of the you know a priori size
there's no dependence on n the number of
queries required is
depends only on k and on the accuracy
parameter epsilon
and that's really sort of the gold
standard that's sometimes called the
constant query testability and property
testing that's what we really want
okay so we've seen a little bit of
sparse recovery or
compressive sensing we've seen a little
bit of property testing what this
work is about is combining these two
strands so we're going to be taking sort
of a property testing look
at a sparse recovery type problem so
what does that mean how would you sort
of formulate things
let's go back to the sparse recovery
setup and remind ourselves of how it
works okay well it's about recovery
we're trying to actually figure out
what is this unknown k sparse vector
from these linear
these linear equations or these labeled
data points
and we saw this you know famous result
uh k log n samples suffice you only need
k log n of these examples in order to do
the recovery
well it's known in fact that for this
recovery problem the login factor is
inherent
this was shown by um i think condobo
pyotr indic a couple of other people and
for a range of different recovery
problems of this sort
you really do need a dependence on m
there's no way to get rid of this login
in order to do the recovery but that's
exactly what we're sort of not happy
with in the property testing context
remember the gold standard is
you know constant sample constant query
testability so this
gives rise i think to a pretty natural
question which is
what if we relax our standards we want
to sort of stay in the
sparse recovery framework where that's
the kind of data that we're working with
but we want to only solve like a testing
type problem we want to solve the sort
of approximate decision version
of the sparse recovery problem so here's
how i think you could kind of naturally
set things up
let's say we have again we are
guaranteed that we're getting
labeled data which is labeled according
to some linear form so we get these
examples
x w dot x again we'll think of ourselves
as just getting these uniform random x's
and we get these w dot x's
corresponding to that so we've got some
unknown vector w
uh say it has two norm one just for some
normalization
and we wanna figure out is it k sparse
or not so we're trying to solve like a
testing for sparsity type question
given the kind of you know access to the
data that we would normally have
in the recovery problem so since it's a
testing problem we're again going to
have these yes and no cases
in the yes case it would be that the
vector is k sparse they're only k
non-zero coefficients and in the no case
it would be that the vector is far from
being k
sparse and a natural sort of notion of
being far from sparse that we'll work
with is that you're far and two norm
from every sparse vector again since the
vector w is a unit vector it's natural
to think about
you know is it the case that you have
euclidean distance at least epsilon from
every k sparse
vector so it's like a testing version of
sparse recovery
sorry to interrupt you two two very
small questions the
the two norm of w being one is unlike in
the half space cases not without loss of
generality so presumably you
you scale with that and also what if
what if you're
you know what if there's a vector v
that's like two case bars
are you going to show far you know a
separation there or
yeah so we'll we'll do we'll we'll see
the results will be quite strong we'll
actually distinguish case bars
from you know from not case bars we
don't have to go to a relaxation we're
like you're far from being 2k sparse or
anything like that
uh you're exactly right that there is
like a built-in scaling here
we would define in general we define um
being far from
the vector w just by like normalizing by
the true norm of w so when i when i say
that like
in this setting where the true norm of w
is one our notion of being
epsilon far from k sparse is that for
every k-sparse vector v
the um the the euclidean distance is one
if i had a general vector w which if i
wasn't assuming to have two norm one i
would just divide
i'd have that the true norm of v minus w
over the true norm of w is at least
epsilon
all right got it thanks a couple of
other questions
is the notion of case velocity in l zero
crucial here could we have a sparsity
in l1 or l2 either in completeness or
soundness
great question um that's a lot to digest
at once let's come back to that at the
very end but for now this is the notion
of sparsity that we're
working with and and elias is asking is
the testing problem actually easier than
the recovery problem
another great question which is
basically the main topic of the talk so
i'll address
i'll address that in the next slide i
think um
yeah so i think this is this is exactly
elias nailed it this is exactly the
question that i think you would want to
answer and this if you accept this kind
of framework
a priori it seems like the testing
problem could be easier
right because we're not trying to do an
actual recovery kind of thing where we
have to you know figure out where the
relevant
coordinates of w are and come up with
these estimates we just want to answer
one we just want to output one bit
um is it sparse or is it far from smart
so can i follow up on this question
rocco for a minute can you hear me
yes i can nice to hear you so uh hi how
are you
so like the question i asked is like if
there is a sort of straightforward
reduction that reduces the testing to to
the
recovery because for example in let's
say distribution testing right testing
whether a distribution is monotone
is uh you know harder than actually
learning a distribution that you have
the promise it's
monotone so like root 10 versus you know
like
something much smaller so in this case
for these problems
can you like immediately reduce the
testing to the recovery like can you
actually get a k log in upper bounds
i yeah if you were to do the recovery
you could then look at your solution and
you could say oh this is
this is a case bars or it's far from
case bars or something like that so i
think the
the learning learning an algorithm for
learning problem i think gives you a
recovery type um
sorry gives you a testing gives you a
testing result but we're interested in
whether
uh you can get testing results that
would be
it could be achieved with a sample
complexity which provably is not enough
samples for learning
right so is there a reason for that that
the sort of learning algorithms in this
case are
like in some sense robust that if you're
not sparse you're like close to sparse
you get something to the closest
sparse approximation um
for sorry i don't understand the
question what is your question
so uh yeah i don't see this reduction
right so so like
you know the learning algorithm like
makes sort of you has an assumption
that you are sparse and then you want to
recover right the testing doesn't make
an assumption doesn't matter you don't
have a promise
you want to test if you're sparse or not
right so in principle if the learning
algorithm doesn't have any sort of
guarantee it's not immediately clear
that you could use it and to test so
unless i'm missing something so sorry to
distract me
let's let me let me not get derailed
here we can talk about it maybe offline
um but the question we're going to be
addressing now is whether we can solve
the decision is the question that the
the main work is about clear to you what
whether we can solve the decision
problem with fewer samples in the
recovery problem
the question is clear i'm just trying to
make this sort of a parallel to other
uh to other sort of related questions
where you do not have
such implications so the the testing
problem is not necessarily easier than
the corresponding learning problem
under the promise okay okay well to
answer this question it turns out that
the answer is yes
uh there is constant the constant sample
testability in this framework
we don't have any dependence on n so to
give you a specific result for the sort
of toy problem that i started off by
talking about
where we're dealing with these uniform
random you know points from the boolean
hypercube as the x's
uh we give a result that that problem
can be solved by the you know in this
testing sense with a sample complexity
which is
k over epsilon to the k so it's worse as
a function of k
than the learning result or the recovery
result but it has no dependence on n is
kind of the big selling point
so this i think just says um on the
slide what i said in words that if we
compare this testing result with the
sparse recovery result we now have an
exponential dependence on k and that's a
that's an open question which we'd be
interested in answering what is the
right
dependence on k for this particular
distribution we don't know what that is
but we don't have any dependence on n so
we've sort of achieved this kind of gold
standard of property testing
and one thing we can mention is it
really is not the case that oh somehow
we're sneaking around and doing like a
learning version
in order to get the testing result if
you think about learning even to name a
single coordinate out of the n
coordinates
that's going to take you log n bits and
we're going to be using just a constant
number of
samples so we're not getting that much
information uh
from our data and again i guess the last
line is just driving in this point that
the
the main sort of thing that we're aiming
for and achieving here is independence
of the ambient dimension
okay so this is a very special case that
i told you about i want to um
now describe some of the more general
results which are actually sort of
the main substance of what we do one
generalization the first one i'll
explain is that
we can actually deal with noise in the
data so
the noisy setting let's say for now that
the noise distribution is independent
gaussian noise
so this is actually going to turn out to
not be very important we'll see that we
can handle almost any noise distribution
although we have to know the noise
distribution that'll come up
that'll come up later but in this
setting for now let's say we just still
have
uh independent x's drawn uniformly from
the hypercube but now we have noisy
labels so we don't just get w dot x we
get w dot x
plus some gaussian noise in the recovery
setting it's known that the sparse
recovery results will still go through
in this kind of framework
and our results also go through in this
kind of framework so we can handle noise
uh without really any problem at all as
we'll see when i kind of sketch some of
the arguments
so let me just back away a little bit
now i want to tell you even more general
versions of the main result but before i
do that let me um
draw a little bit of a contrast with
kind of the standard results in property
testing
that we maybe are a little bit more used
to so again
in kind of traditional property testing
at least a boolean functions what's
going on we usually assume we have some
kind of query access
we usually assume we're dealing with a
boolean valued function
uh we usually don't consider the
possibility of having noise in the data
so
the differences i would want to
highlight here are really along these
the lines of these three bullet points
we're dealing with real valued functions
so that's that's one kind of substantial
difference from maybe hunter testing
we're making an assumption about the
functions we're assuming that we are
dealing with a linear function and
within that class of functions
we just want to figure out whether it's
sparse or far from sparse
okay another difference of course is
like we said we're going to be able to
deal with
having noise in the data and finally a
big difference
is that again in most studies of
property testing for boolean functions
we assume that we get
this kind of query access eric was sort
of
exploring i think a variant of the model
which is a very interesting one and
deserves i think more attention than
it's gotten
where you only have access to random
samples but that's a little bit
unusual vis-a-vis sort of standard
boolean function property testing
results
but the spirit of what we're trying to
achieve is really very closely in line
with sort of standard property testing
we're interested in getting constant
sample testability we don't want to have
a dependence on
on n okay
so this is just a slide you've seen
before it's just a restatement
of the result in this special case that
we've been talking about i want to
highlight
the things that are in red because those
are things that we'll be changing when
we go to a more general problem
formulation in the next slide
so this is just saying if i have noisy
data now let's say that the noise comes
from a normal
distribution again my sort of
distribution over the x's
over the random samples i get is uniform
over the hypercube
so this is just a restatement of the
result we said earlier we can
have this efficient testing algorithm it
makes a number
it needs a number of samples which is
independent of n it's basically k over
epsilon to the k
and it'll successfully solve this
testing problem if the function is k
sparse if the vector is k sparse it'll
say yes
if it's far from k sparse it'll say no
so now we'll generalize this in a couple
of ways
um and the generalizations are again
highlighted in red for you
so we'll be handling basically any noise
distribution as long as the noise
distribution has moments of all orders
which even that is a little bit of a
stronger condition than we actually
require
we can handle any kind of noise
distribution although we'll have to know
the distribution
of the noise and we'll come back to
seeing why that's the case in a minute
so that's one generalization another
generalization is
we're going to go from just the uniform
distribution over the boolean hypercube
to a much more general setting of being
able to handle arbitrary product
distributions
so the underlying distribution over the
x's remember x is an n-dimensional
vector it's going to have to be an
iid product distribution but it could be
basically any distribution with one
asterisk as long as each
coordinate marginal of the distribution
is non-gaussian so the underlying
one-dimensional distribution
can be pretty much anything it needs to
have moments of all orders
it can't be a gaussian okay
so if you give me access to this data
from an iid
product distribution where each you know
component the underlying you know
distribution over the reals is
non-gaussian you give me access to this
kind of noisy data with basically any
type of noise model
then it turns out that we have the same
testing result so again we can
distinguish
k-sparse vectors from far from k-sparse
factors and the sample and time
complexity
won't have any dependence on the
dimension they'll just be
you can see there's a dependence on this
underlying distribution d
sort of that core univariate
distribution that will come into the
picture
there will be some dependence on what is
the particular noise distribution
depends on k depends on epsilon
but no dependence on the dimension n
okay so this is basically the most
general version of the main result i
guess
strictly speaking we can do something
more general because we can actually do
tolerant testing or distance estimation
we won't just uh tell you whether or not
your k sparse or far from k sparse
we'll output an accurate estimate of the
distance to
the um the nearest the nearest vector
the nearest case sparse vector but if
you
don't care about tolerant testing you
can ignore this and um just think about
this as being our general result so sort
of arbitrary product distributions which
are not gaussian
if we know the noise we can solve this
testing problem um
with it with no dependence on the
dimension now
okay so at this point you might be
thinking these are
slightly weird results it seems like you
know you have these various asterisks
there you can't handle a gaussian
distribution you sort of need to know
this noise
distribution and so on and so forth so
we also have a range of lower bounds
which show that if i take away any of
those conditions then actually you can't
get this kind of
qualitatively matching result where
there's you know where the sample
complexity is independent of the
dimension
so i'll tell you in the next three
slides about three lower bounds which
say that basically if you take away any
of these conditions
um then the sample complexity of the
testing problem
becomes as hard as the learning problem
it'll go it'll go all the way back up to
log n so i'll tell you about these lower
bounds the first one basically is
this gaussian condition it says you're
not going to be able to solve this
problem
with a sample complexity independent of
n if the distribution is gaussian and
this is true even if you're just
considering
the simplest case of one sparsity as a
comment
in this vein this is why we sort of
inherently have to have a dependence if
i go back a couple of slides
on the underlying ambient distribution d
zero that's why there's this sort of o
sub d 0
in the sample complexity because it
should be easy to imagine if my
distribution were very very close to a
gaussian
well it would be sort of getting harder
and harder to solve this problem
the closer it is to a gaussian then you
can you can work out rigorous statements
um
along those lines which we do but anyway
yeah this first lower bound says you
know that this restriction and our
positive result
the distribution can't be gaussian is
real there's there is no efficient
algorithm
um if the underlying distribution is
gaussian
the second lower bound result says it's
really not enough to have a product
distribution you need an iid product
distribution if you want again this
constant
sample complexity so if it's not iid if
the distribution is allowed to even just
have two different possibilities for
what each
sort of coordinate wise marginal is say
poisson one or it could be poisson two
then again it's uh provably impossible
to have a constant sample complexity
you'll need to have sample complexity
um which is as bad as in the recovery
case it's going to have to grow like
login
so this iid assumption for the product
distributions is really necessary
and the third assumption is that you
really do need to as we kind of
stipulated know the noise distribution
i can give you an example of a simple um
product distribution
where if you don't know what the noise
is it could be one of two possibilities
it's either poisson one or poisson two
and you don't know which one it is
then again this kind of logarithmic n
lower bound kicks in
so in order to get the sort of constant
sample
testability which is our main goal you
really do need all these conditions that
are
in our main theorem statement
so i don't want to really say much more
about the lower bounds and the rest of
the talk i was going to give you some of
the ideas
of the upper bounds for the upper bounds
there are essentially two different
algorithms there's a simpler algorithm
for kind of
the clean case that i started off with
where we just have
the underlying distribution is uniform
over the hypercube and then there's a
somewhat more complicated algorithm for
the more general case of like an
arbitrary distribution
so um yeah i'll try to say a little bit
about each of those settings but maybe
just to motivate sort of the upcoming
discussion
the natural questions which come to mind
at this point are okay there's there's a
positive result as long as the
underlying distribution is not gaussian
like why is that the case how
how does it sort of emerge that you can
handle non-gaussian distributions
but you can't handle gaussian
distributions um okay
we also will try to figure out you know
why what is the dependence on these
the distribution the noise these types
of things um
so to get us going on actually
understanding some of the results really
the key notion that underlies
all of our positive results is the idea
of working with the cumulants of the
underlying
univariate distribution so let's remind
ourselves of just the very basics here
if we have uh joe has a question
um do we know that the first coordinate
in the in the second lower bound do we
know that the first set of coordinates
of poisson one
and the second set of coordinates the
person two or are they mixed up in
a manner which we do not know i believe
if i remember correctly even if you know
that the first one is one and the second
one is two
it's uh that doesn't help you because
you basically don't the sparsity pattern
you know if it's case sparse versus
non-case for so you don't know how that
would be mixed up in the one way or the
other so you can assume that you know
that
okay oh no i see the question so quick
quick question is this problem at all
related to these problems on
non-gaussian component analysis where
you have access to some samples and and
it can be decomposed into some you know
from some ambient space and it can be
decomposed it's some product of like a
non-gaussian gaussian component and
there are some algorithms that depend on
like exactly
you know how much you differ from the
moment of gaussian in a particular
direction interesting i don't know of
connections there but i don't know this
line of work well so there might be
there might be connections
uh adam so very briefly i mean both i
mean this is also going to use some
notion about cumulatives and
i guess those also use some notion of
turbulence
right i mean there's technical
similarity it's not
uh there's some technical similarities
certainly like you know the
fact that the cumulative for gaussian is
by characterizing of the distribution is
going to be central here as well okay
yeah this is previewing the next couple
of the next couple of slides so
okay yeah so let's remind ourselves of
the basics of cumulants
um what are the cumulants of a
distribution well we know what the
moments of a distribution are right if
we want to think about the moments um
we can you know recall this moment
generating function which is sort of a
wave encoding all the moments of a
distribution
um just by having them be the
coefficients of a taylor expansion for
the
for the generating function um so the
cumulants you can define as just you
take the moment generating function
take its log and now look at the
coefficients in the taylor expansion of
that function
and those coefficients correspond to the
cumulus of the underlying distribution
okay so i guess strictly speaking the
jth cumulant is what you get if you take
the um
cumulative generating function you just
you know break it down in terms of doing
the taylor expansion and
it sort of corresponds to exactly like
the role of the moments in the moment
generating function but
you're starting with log of the moment
generating function instead of the
original moment generating function
okay so given this notion of cumulates
even at the sort of very high level of
which i just described it it's probably
clear that if i give you the cumulus of
a distribution you can get the moments
back and vice versa
and indeed they're really really nicely
related for the first couple of
cumulants the
first cumulant is the mean the second
cumulant is the variance
and then it starts to get uglier the
third cumulant doesn't have a such a
nice expression or a nice
way to describe it so on and so forth
but you can see if i gave you the
cumulants
if i give you the moment sorry you can
obviously write down the cumulants there
are just you know
expressions for this and you can go the
other direction as well
so sort of knowing one um is as good as
knowing the other
however that doesn't mean that working
with one is always sort of as convenient
as working with the other one and it
turns out that for our purposes
cumulants have some really nice
properties which make things go through
in a clean way
the key properties and we'll see this is
really almost everything we need
uh are really just two basic properties
the first one is linearity if you have
two independent random variables
then unlike moments the um sum of the
the j
cumulative of the sum is the sum of the
cumulatives so they decompose
independent random variables decompose
in a very nice way
for cumulatives here for every j and
similarly they have this nice
homogeneity property
right if you scale a random variable by
c it scales the cumulant in sort of the
obvious way
so this is going to turn out to be
absolutely uh really really convenient
for us to have these properties
a couple of other facts about cumulants
which we'll end up using are that
um the accumulants of just you know this
very simple
uh radamacher distribution plus one
minus one with equal probabilities
one-half
we can write down what those cumulatives
are it's just a little exercise to
figure out that basically they're zero
if j
is odd and they're they grow as j to the
j if j is even
um on the other hand for gaussians the
cumulants have this very interesting
property that you know again
the first cumulant is the mean the
second cumulative is the variance but
then
for any gaussian random variable all of
the subsequent cumulants turn out to be
zero
so q1's three four up through infinity
they're all zero for gaussians and
this will be important for us
okay so at this point we know enough to
go through a sketch of
the simple special case that we started
off the talk with where we think about
the underlying distribution is being
just
uniform plus one minus one to the n that
that's where the x's come from
so in the next few slides i'll sketch
for you how in that setting
you know given given let's say data
where we have
gaussian noise although again we'll see
that the noise doesn't really matter
we'll be able to come up with this
constant sample testing algorithm to
distinguish between k
sparse you know linear forms versus far
from k sparse linear forms
okay so how does it work really it
leverages the
linearity and homogeneity that's almost
all it does
so the just to remind ourselves of the
basic setup we get these samples so we
get the n bit string
x and then we get w dot x plus the noise
okay and remember each of the
coordinates of x is just this bernoulli
plus one minus one equally likely random
variable and we're going to assume for
now that the noise is gaussian
so okay i get these samples of this you
know w dot x plus noise i can certainly
draw a bunch of these samples and
estimate the cumulants for any j that
i'm interested in i can
come up with a high accuracy estimate of
the j cumulent of that random variable y
which is just my stand in for w dot x
plus plus the noise
and now you know given the nature of the
way the um the data that the data is
structured
i can just use these linearity and
homogeneity properties to say well
i have w dot x plus independent noise so
the
linearity lets me split those two pieces
apart and then w dot
x well i can just use the um homogeneity
property to say that the j
cumulative that part is just going to be
this sum of
uh w i to the j times the j cumulative
the bernoulli
okay so this is just the part in red the
key part is just an immediate
consequence of these basic properties of
cumulatives
so what does that mean it means that
basically um i can figure out or i can i
can come up with some kind of estimate
of this
j sort of power sum symmetric polynomial
so this is the jth polynomial would be
like the sum of w1 to the j
plus w2 to the j plus so on and so forth
i just solved this simple equation in
red
and i have that this j power symmetric
polynomial has this expression in terms
of
the j cumulent of the the labels that i
get the label distribution the jth
cumulative the noise
and the jth cumulative of the bernoulli
distribution
so now you can imagine you're in pretty
good shape this is just the same the
same thing as on the last slide
uh i can really come up with estimates
or in some cases i actually exactly know
these quantities on the right hand side
i have access to these
labeled examples these draws from the y
distribution
um for the gaussian if i assume that my
noise is gaussian well then actually
these jth
of the noise distribution are zero so
there's nothing to do there but even if
i didn't
have gaussian noise as long as i knew
the noise distribution i could just
compute these jth cumulants of the noise
distribution
and finally again it's some kind of
exercise to
down and figure out what are the jth
cumulants of the bernoulli distribution
so we can figure out a good estimate of
everything on the right-hand side
we can in other words we can come up
with a high accuracy estimate of this
j power sum polynomial in these
coefficients that we're interested in w1
through wn
okay yes this is just saying the same
thing i can figure out what's on the
right hand side or i can come up with a
high accuracy estimate
so i can work out for any j that i'm
interested in you know what is the sum
of the squares of these coefficients
what's the sum of the fourth powers
what's the sum of the sixth powers so on
and so forth it's convenient to work
just with the um
just with the even powers i think i see
a question from clement
um does lower bound on gaussian d
still apply if eight is not gaussian
itself
that's a good question let me come back
to it at the end of the talk
um yeah i'll come back to that at the
very end
okay we're continuing continuing here we
see that
hopefully it's clear from this even this
high level sketch that we can actually
come up with high accuracy estimates of
these
uh power sum polynomials so okay it's
nice to have these estimates of the
power sum polynomials but if we're
interested in figuring out whether or
not
our underlying weight vector is k sparse
we might want to have a
you know some other kind of information
about the vector and it turns out that
um you know these other elementary
symmetric polynomials just that the sort
of more
standard elementary symmetric
polynomials turn out to be more
convenient for
for doing that kind of analysis so i
think i've written down here just a
basic
expression for what is the you know j
elementary symmetric polynomial it's
just the sum overall i guess n choose j
multi-linear monomials corresponding to
you know picking every possible subset
of the j variables and adding them up
i'm working with the um
squared weights here again because it's
it's more convenient for what we're
doing
so we have these well-known you know
identities which say if i give you the
first j
elementary symmetric polynomials you can
figure out what the j the power sum
polynomial is and it goes in the other
direction as well if i give you the
first j
power sum polynomials you can figure out
the j elementary symmetric polynomial
okay so we can again kind of go back and
forth between these two things
um and again just reminding ourselves
from a few slides back
we can estimate uh these power sum
polynomials
with just k to the k samples and this is
again because the sort of sample
complexity if we
go back really came from the um came
from the denominator here the fact that
the jth cumulant
uh for the for the plus one minus one
distribution was like j
to the j so that's where that sample
complexity is coming from
so good we can estimate these uh power
sum symmetric polynomials
that means in turn we can estimate the
elementary symmetric polynomials
and now having a good handle on the
elementary symmetric polynomials really
tells us what we want to know in terms
of whether or not the underlying vector
is k sparse
so these are just very basic
observations suppose you have a k sparse
vector
okay then if i look at the j plus first
elementary symmetric polynomial it's
going to be zero because every monomial
i'm multiplying together
k plus one thing so i'm always
multiplying together multiplying in a
zero
into every sum and in the k plus first
elementary symmetric polynomial
okay so that first observation is super
easy
and the second observation the converse
is equally easy right if i have that the
um k plus first elementary symmetric
polynomial in these squared weights
which are always non-negative is zero
well then actually each of those
summands must have been
zero it has to be the k which means that
the vector has to be k sparse if there
was even a single
you know monomial of k plus one with
nonzero elements multiplying together i
wouldn't be getting zero out
um for the k plus first elementary
symmetric polynomial
so you can see probably this converse is
going exactly in the kind of direction
that we want
uh in our testing scenario we actually
need a robust version of the converse
but that's not very difficult to come up
with right so the converse said
i guess that if w is not k sparse then
the k
plus first elementary symmetric
polynomial is non-zero
and you can robustify this it's a pretty
simple i think it's an inductive
argument that if
your weight vector w is far from k
sparse
then in fact the k plus first elementary
symmetric polynomial has to
not just be non-zero but you can give a
lower bound on its magnitude
okay so given this robust version of the
converse it's probably pretty clear how
you would put these pieces together
to actually come up with a testing
algorithm again the algorithm gets
access to these
labeled examples it doesn't actually use
the individual bits of x so it really
just uses
statistical estimates of the labels this
w dot x plus noise this y
part um and again how does it work it
estimates these cumulatives
uh given estimates of the cumulants we
were able to figure out estimates of
these elementary these are these power
sum
symmetric polynomials so the sum of the
squares sum of the fourth powers sum of
the sixth powers
so on and so forth given estimates of
those power sum symmetric polynomials we
can estimate the elementary symmetric
polynomials
and then we just saw that if the vector
was k sparse this
l k plus first elementary symmetric
polynomial will be zero
whereas if the vector was far from k
sparse then this k
plus first elementary symmetric
polynomial will be bounded away from
zero
so we can successfully you know come up
with the right answer
um in each of these cases whether the
vector is k-sparse
or far from k-sparse so that's a sketch
of the simple result the result in the
case where the underlying distribution
was
uniform over the boolean hypercube are
there any questions
about that result
okay um if not then i'll move on
so we saw that really the crucial thing
for that result was that we were able to
estimate these elementary
sorry these power sum polynomials and
how are we able to estimate these power
sum polynomials well again it just came
from this very simple identity which
you know is a direct result of the
linearity and homogeneity of cumulants
you know we have this division when we
solve for the power sum polynomial we
have the cumulative the underlying
univariate distribution which in our
case was just the springly one-half
on the right-hand side um so you know
this worked out well for us because the
the
plus one minus one uniform distribution
has these non-zero cumulatives
so what we wrote down makes sense right
this is a quantity that we could hope to
estimate
um the noise didn't really matter again
that was just this you know minus the j
accumulant of the noise on top as long
as i know what the noise is
i can handle that no problem but it's
more interesting it's more challenging
what's going on in the denominator when
we were dealing with these
uh uniform plus one minus one bits okay
we
know what those cumulates are and we can
proceed
how are we gonna handle a more general
case um you can see already probably
that if those cumulants are zero we're
going to be in trouble
and that's indeed what happens so let me
remind you now in i guess most of the
rest of the talk i'll
give you um some sense of the argument
behind the general
theorem so the general theorem we're
trying to generalize again the sort of
issue of the noise is not so
important or not so tough to handle but
we want to think now about you know
okay i no longer have plus 1 minus 1 as
my distribution over each coordinate
instead i have a general
distribution over the reals and as we
saw the result is going to require that
the distribution is non-gaussian so we'd
like to figure out now how can we solve
this
this more general problem well
the natural thing to do is try to do
just what we did before right
just instead of having the bernoulli
distribution sorry the um
instead of having this yeah this this
bernoulli plus or minus one distribution
as the underlying distribution we just
have this ambient distribution d
zero again we can express these uh power
sum polynomials in terms of
the j cumulative the the labels these
y's which we we can estimate
from our samples the j cumulative the
noise the other term in the numerator
which we can handle
um and now in the denominator though we
have this j cumulative the underlying
distribution
and this could be zero conceivably right
maybe it's the case that
um for one of these cumulants which we
would like to to
carry out this estimate and come up with
the j the power sum polynomial
it doesn't make any sense because we're
dividing by zero in fact
maybe something even worse happens where
we actually end up always dividing by
zero for every
um even value of j that we would be
wanting to be using in our algorithm
so these would be problems and you can
probably see the connection with the
gaussian challenge that arises now
for i guess the second cumulative when j
is two nothing bad can really happen
right we know that the second cumulative
is just the variance so as long as i
have a non-trivial distribution
you know i'll never be dividing by zero
because of j equals two
but we saw that if the underlying
distribution is gaussian then
that's where sort of you know the good
news ends all the higher cumulants are
zero
and so the algorithm really just can't
work right there's uh
there's not going to be any larger value
of j for which it's possible to carry
this out
but crucially um it turns out that
having a gaussian distribution
is kind of the only distribution which
can completely
scuttle this this attempt uh the reason
for this is this
classical theorem due to marcenkovic
which says that
if you come to me with any distribution
which is not a gaussian any distribution
which has you know
some non-trivial difference from a
gaussian then in fact it's going to have
to have
not just some non-zero cumulants after j
equals two it's going to have to have
infinitely many non-zero cubes
so this kind of tells us oh there should
be like a lot of um
a lot of uh tools at our disposal that
hopefully we can use you know these
non-zero cumulatives of higher order
in order to make something like our
approach work
and indeed that is the case but it's not
we can't use the same simple algorithm
based just on these symmetric
polynomials that we used in the earlier
case
so let's consider now the setting in
which you know the distribution is not a
gaussian and again parenthetically we
know from the lower bound there's no
hope when it has a gaussian right
there's no way we're going to be able to
make it work so
we fix it we fixate now in the case in
which the underlying distribution is
non-gaussian
okay we know we have infinitely many
non-zero accumulants but
you know just because i have infinitely
many non-zero cumulatives that certainly
doesn't mean that cumulus 2
4 6 8 10 12 the ones which we needed in
order to reconstruct
the uh elementary symmetric polynomials
will be non-zero it's easy to come up
with examples where you know the fourth
cumulant is zero or the sixth
cumulant is zero and in that case we
can't make our simple algorithm work
so we need to come up with a somewhat
new algorithm the idea
underlying it is very simple it's just
that you know
uh if i go to higher and higher
um norms of a vector those basically
start to look like the infinity norm and
if you can figure out the infinity norm
of the vector
well maybe i can get rid of maybe i can
sort of take away
elements of the vector piece by piece by
piece and that's exactly what our
algorithm does it turns out to be this
iterative kind of thing where we
estimate the largest magnitude entry of
the vector
we compensate for it basically subtract
it away
then we estimate the next largest
magnitude entry of the vector subtract
it away and
do something iterative like this so i'll
take you through a high level
sketch of some of it but i won't go into
too many details
um this is just a basic lemma which says
something we
were all comfortable with i think just
that if i have a um
if i have a vector let's say the two
norm is at most one i'm willing to look
at a large enough
uh norm of the vector the t norm for t
something like one over delta cubed
then that'll be delta close to the
infinity norm of the vector
okay so in principle i'd like to figure
out you know exactly what is the
magnitude of the largest component to
this vector i won't be able to do that
exactly but if i'm
if i'm able to estimate a large enough
norm of the vector that should be that
should be morally just as good as
getting the exact infinity norm of the
vector
so okay what's the high level idea of
the algorithm basically it needs a
sequence
of uh very very well we'll see these
values gonna have to be very fast
growing but a sequence of different sort
of indices such that all of those
cumulants are non-zero
okay so i want you know the a1 cumulent
is non-zero
that's a very large value and somewhat
lower than that i have that the a-tooth
cumulative the distribution is non-zero
and smaller than that so on and so forth
something like this so i have these
non-zero cumulates
uh k or k plus one of them i think is
going to be good enough for me
okay let's consider say this largest
value this a1 value
we saw earlier right since this 81
cumulative is non-zero just in the
simple expression i have a non-zero
denominator i can
actually estimate um this a1
elementary power sum polynomial good so
i have
some kind of estimate of the sum of the
a1 powers of this weight vector
okay since a1 was chosen to be very very
large this is a high accuracy estimate
of the largest magnitude entry in the
weight vector so i basically know
the biggest value in the vector the
largest magnitude value in the vector
and you know i'd like to now somehow
strip it away and recurse so this is
just
for the purpose of sort of you know
having clean notation let's assume that
the
entries of the vector are ordered from
largest to smallest magnitude as we go
through the elements of the vector
um you know since i basically know what
is this largest value
i can i can subtract it out when i do my
estimates
of the other uh power sum polynomials
and that means that really i can sort of
you know do what i just did but working
with
sort of this simplified version of the
vector where i've taken away that
largest magnitude element
okay so you just you know you can
compensate i know what this largest
magnitude
value was i figure out some power sum um
polynomial in these things i can
subtract away
the appropriate power of that largest
value and now it's it's like i'm working
with the
um the sort of truncated vector where
i've gotten rid of that large value
so you can imagine how something like
this would go right you start with this
very very large
very very large norm you get an estimate
using that of the largest magnitude
entry of the vector
then you go down to some somewhat
smaller norm you again sort of
recursively do the same kind of thing we
just did to figure out
an estimate of the next largest element
of the vector and so on and so forth you
do this k times
you'll actually come up with high
accuracy estimates
of the k largest elements of this weight
vector
and once you've done that you're pretty
much home so we've
worked out now estimates of the k
largest elements of the vector
and we want to know well is this vector
k first or is it far from k
sparse i guess we're assuming that the
true norm of the vector is one but
even if we don't make that assumption
something we can always do with j equals
two is just figure out the
um degree two power sum polynomial the
sum of the squares of the elements of
this vector
so if i have these high accuracy
estimates of the k largest elements of
the vector
and i know the sum of the squares of all
the elements of the vector
you know obviously that's exactly the
information i need to tell whether the
original vector is k sparse
or whether it's in fact you know has
some non-negligible distance from
k-sparse
i think it should be clear also that
this is enough information
to let us do tolerant testing or
distance estimation
right we just see how much of the um
some of the squares is left
after we've taken out these k largest
elements
uh okay good so hopefully that made
sense
but if we want to think a little bit
more from like an effective algorithms
perspective about how this would
actually work okay what did we say we
did we said okay we're going to work
with these
k values a1 a2 a3 these very large
values such that i actually know that
the
cumulus of the uh
underlying distribution the a1
cumulative truth cumulative
and so forth uh are all non-zero okay so
if i know the distribution presumably i
know
i could i could in principle figure out
these these large values
and i know that the distribution has you
know as many non-zero accumulants as i
need so that's that's
good news that means that this should be
doable at least in principle
but if you say to yourself okay how
would this really play out in practice
it would be nice to know something about
um how far you have to go right
this result of marcin kavitch says okay
the distribution you started with as
long as it's not a gaussian i promise
you that
there are infinitely many non-zero
cumulants but
a reasonable person could say well you
know given this particular distribution
can you tell me
sort of where those non-zero cumulants
are can you tell me you know you're
telling me they're non-zero
are they extremely close to zero because
if they are that's going to you know
make my
it's going to affect my algorithms
running time and so on so these are
these are i think natural questions to
sort of
try to bring this a little bit closer to
an effective algorithm
um so yeah again in order to run the
algorithm you need to know actually
where are these non-zero accumulants
and maybe if we don't know exactly you
know where these non-zero accumulates
are it would be nice at least to know
how far do you have to go
in order to reach the non-zero
cumulatives that you need so
the last result i'll tell you about is
kind of a constructive
version of this marcin cavitch theorem
which says
uh you know under some mild conditions
on the underlying distribution
we will tell you something about how far
out you have to go
you know do you have to go to the 100th
cumulant you have to go to the 10 to the
100th cumulant
how high up do you need to go to get a
non-zero accumulant and how large will
that cumulative be
okay so this is again kind of like a
constructive version of the marston
cavity theorem you need to assume
something right because again if your
distribution is
you know closer and closer and closer to
a gaussian well it's going to be worse
and worse and worse in terms of
closer and closer and closer to really
having um
only extremely small or all zero
accumulants so the theorem that we're
able to
um give along these lines says if you
have a
symmetric random variable so symmetry is
a straightforward thing you can
symmetrize just by subtracting two
examples from each other
so suppose you have a symmetric random
variable let's normalize to say the
variance is one
and the real meaningful assumption we
make is that it has bounded support it's
supported between some
minus c and c value what we're able to
say is that under those conditions if
you
sort of have a starting point you're
interested in like you know the teeth
cumulative the t plus first cumulative t
plus second cumulative
how far do i have to go to get a
non-zero guy
the result says that if you start at the
teeth cumulant you only have to go up to
the
basically exponential in teeth you know
consider that many
possibilities for the cumulant and you
will find
a non-zero guy within that range so
given any t
there's going to be some cumulative
between the teeth and 2c to the teeth
cumulate which is not only non-zero but
it's actually bounded away from zero
by this sort of doubly exponential
function of t
so in principle at least this sort of
tells you you don't have to go
too too you know it's not the case that
sort of i can't say anything about
how far up you have to go in order to
get k non-zero cumulates
but you can also see this is not going
to give you a great result right i sort
of have this tower of exponentials to
get the k-th non-zero cumulant
i have to iterate this thing k times so
i end up with a tower of k
tower of height k to uh but i can say
that you know within that tower i will
have k non-zero cumulants and
that's sort of enough in order to run
this algorithm
so we searched the literature a fair bit
before kind of rolling up our sleeves i
should say an indian tray rolling up
their sleeves to actually prove this
constructive marcin kavitch theorem
we weren't able to find results of this
form in the literature i think it's a
natural question
um whether you can perhaps do
substantially better it may be the case
that
um under different assumptions or you
can get a much stronger quantitative
conclusion
about how far up you have to go in order
to get these non-zero cumulants and
that would be interesting it would tell
us something about the um the running
time of the
the running time of the algorithm for
distributions that satisfy these
conditions
so i'm basically done just to wrap up in
a last
slide or two we saw that the high-level
um
message of what this talk is about is
we're sort of looking at a sparse
recovery type question
from a property testing vantage point
we're interested in
kind of the framework of sparse recovery
but we're lazy we don't want to actually
recover the unknown vector we just want
to figure out whether or not it's
sparse versus far from sparse and for a
fairly general
class of distributions we can do this we
can you know sort of get a satisfying
testing result with a sample complexity
that's independent
of the ambient dimension and although
the um
testing complexity it you know it's a
little bit reminiscent of like these
graph property testing things where you
have a tower
um type dependence in terms of the uh
the query complexity so that that seems
to be where we stand
um it's tolerant testing like we said it
has this robustness property
so this is the last slide i think a
couple of interesting questions for
future work or you know it'd be nice to
have
stronger quantitative statements even in
this very clean setting of say
you know plus one minus one to the n the
uniform distribution
uh it's not at all clear that the result
we have there which was just this like k
to the k
query sample complexity is correct maybe
it's the case that you can you can solve
that testing problem
where the distribution is uniform over
the hypercube with a polynomial k
dependent so
i think that would be interesting to
think about um i think it's also
interesting to think about going beyond
just testing sort of
sparse linear functions you could ask
analogous questions
if um you're interested in maybe low
degree polynomials instead of linear
functions or
some kind of passing it through some
kind of
some kind of function like a logistic
function or something like that or a
sigmoid
to again extend sort of beyond just
thinking about linear functions and
the last sort of broader question which
i think eric has gone a long ways toward
answering with the work he told us about
earlier is
sort of in general trying to understand
this relationship between testing
and learning in a sample-based type of
setting so the next time i give this
talk i think thanks to eric's
work that he told us about maybe i can
put a check mark by this last open
question
so i think that's it thank you
thank you rocco i greatly enjoyed
learning about the result
uh so uh
uh so any uh so uh i'll i never had a
question in the middle of the talk but
we
kept it for the end so does the test
from repeating the question now
does the testing question make sense for
deterministic queries but where the
matrix of queries
satisfies some pseudo-randomness
condition like r.i.p or incoherence for
recovery
yeah that's a good question i think you
could formulate
meaningful um meaningful variants of the
meaningful variance of types of
questions we're looking at along those
lines we haven't really
thought about them at all um but yeah i
think that's i think that's a direction
you could you could ask about
uh then sorry uh clermont also the
question
would anything be simpler if you had
query access
or active learning type access
uh regarding sample complexity sorry
yeah
yeah so question a little bit in the
other direction i think the answer is
yes there are a range of techniques you
can try to use
um if you have query access i think it
makes the problem considerably easier i
remember in the early stages of when we
were working on this i would
keep on proposing to an india oh why
don't we do this and he would be for
like the ninth time in a row he would
have to say rocco you know we don't get
queries in this model we just
we just have the random example so yeah
i think that queries do give you so with
queries you just have a hunter right
so you can probably do basically i mean
it's a real valid function but you can
probably do hunter testing
you can do these kinds of things yeah
and and again it has this we're assuming
a lot of structure it's
you know that it's linear so it's yeah i
think it's a
it seems to have a pretty different
flavor um and i think it's an easier
it seems a lot easier if you get queries
um do we have any other questions
well okay there were lots of questions
okay so
if not then uh thank you ako uh so the
next
talk is by diana which is in 15 minutes
so
let's take a 15 minute break and we will
be back
at 2 30 eastern times 11 30
pacific time thank you